Hola Muy bienvenidos una nueva emisión
de la entrevista de Franz 24 en español
en esta oportunidad nos acompaña Félix
Ulloa vicepresidente de El Salvador
señor usó a Muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en la entrevista de Franz 24
en español
es un gusto Muchas gracias por la
oportunidad No gracias a usted una vez
más bueno vicepresidente hablemos para
comenzar de lo que es el plan Control
territorial y el régimen de excepción no
en El Salvador para luchar contra la
violencia que propagan las pandillas los
grupos criminales impulsado por supuesto
por el presidente nayib bukele ya lleva
10 meses no definitivamente han reducido
los índices de violencia han
desarticulado a muchos grupos criminales
parecen haber ganado no la guerra contra
las pandillas pero la forma en la que lo
han hecho generó miles de denuncias por
presuntas violaciones a los Derechos
Humanos muchas críticas señalan por
ejemplo pérdida de garantías
constitucionales de los ciudadanos que
se permiten detenciones arbitrarias
detenciones incluso a menores de edad
que violarían según organizaciones los
derechos del niño human right watch
denuncia torturas y muertes de personas
bajo custodia del estado que responde
usted vicepresidente a estas denuncias y
estas críticas
Bueno mira lo que te podría decir es que
en primer lugar los grupos que hacen
estas denuncias no tienen la información
exacta precisa en algunos casos hechos
aislados tratan de magnificarlos no son
denuncias que respondan a la realidad de
lo que sucede en el país y podríamos
irlo viendo una por una por ejemplo
cuando se dice de que se han violentado
los derechos de los niños porque se han
capturado menores de edad pues las
pandillas prácticamente se nutrían de
menores de edad y justamente por ser un
menor de edad el que no estaba siendo
juzgado conforme de la legislación común
utilizaban estos menores para cometer
delitos no solo delitos menores de ir a
cobrar las extorsiones sino incluso los
usaban de gatilleros y habían muchos
menores niños de 12 14 años que tenía
sus hombros ya varios homicidios sea
pues que no se trata de niños
Boy Scout o los niños cantores de Viena
se trata de Pequeños menores que han
cometido delitos graves cuando se habla
también de que desde el régimen de
excepción ha afectado la garantías
constitucionales pareciera ser que
estamos en estado de sitio que los
salvadoreños estamos limitados en
nuestras libertades públicas y lo cual
es una falsedad nunca desde que se
decretó el estado de excepción se afectó
una sola garantía de las libertades
públicas ni una sola las cuatro las
únicas cuatro garantías que se
suspendieron al inicio tienen que ver
con garantías individuales para poder
sustanciar procesos judiciales con una
excepción o suspensión en el caso por
ejemplo de la detención administrativa
que la Constitución la garantiza en tres
días y ahora se extendió a quince días o
el derecho del año delabilidad de las de
las escuchas Y que ahora pues para poder
revisar los teléfonos de los criminales
pues hubo que suspender esa garantía Es
decir Fueron cuatro garantías Ahora solo
son dos las que están suspendidas
Entonces no hay que hablar de que están
suspendiéndose la garantía
constitucional en El Salvador pareciera
ser Pues que se lo explicaba yo a una
cancillería en Europa porque me decía
tenemos temor de que no se pueda
movilizar el pueblo en El Salvador y le
decía hombre si hay que ir a las playas
hay que ir a ver los eventos deportivos
hay que ver las actividades religiosas
que se desarrollaron una semana después
de que se estaban suspendiendo de esta
garantías entonces hay que ir
entendiendo exactamente de qué se trata
que se han muerto personas en los
penales bajo responsabilidad del estado
creo que se denunciaron cincuenta
fallecimientos cuando el promedio normal
en los años anteriores revisando el
histórico de los fallecimientos en anda
arriba de cien fallecimientos por año de
aquí no Hemos llegado ni siquiera Pues a
ese número pero esta narrativa se ha
utilizado por parte de la oposición
política en El Salvador que al no tener
los partidos que fueron derrotados en
las elecciones ninguna vocería legítima
han utilizado algunas ongs A fines que a
su vez pasan la información a esta ong
que de basada en Washington que tú
mencionas y se replican esta mentira Y
va creciendo y sin mayor análisis y
rigor periodístico se repiten estas
estas medias verdades señor usual
hablemos ahora de la reciente
inauguración de lo que es la cárcel más
grande de América Latina con capacidad
para alrededor de 40.000 reclusos este
hecho reavivó un debate sobre lo que
algunas personas críticas también no
consideran un enfoque punitivista del
plan Control territorial no que se iba a
cabo el gobierno de El Salvador esto
significaría que no estarían atacando
las causas estructurales que impulsan
quizás a personas a formar parte de
estos grupos criminales no faltas de
oportunidades económicas citan algunos
marginalización social entre otras sino
que atacan más bien las consecuencias
Cómo definiría usted el enfoque del plan
Control y que responde a esto sobre el
punitivismo
es exactamente lo mismo es decir el
puñetivismo está en el en el ADN de los
sistemas penales en todos los países
nuestros al contrario en El Salvador se
ha tratado de evolucionar con un nuevo
derecho penitenciario en el cual no solo
se ha dado lo que se llama la segunda
oportunidad sino que hay un programa de
tratamiento de reos En fase de confianza
que pues pueden salir de los penales y
realizar labores sociales reconstrucción
de escuelas recoger basuras pintar
edificios públicos en fin están este
contingente de reos que se llama En fase
de confianza pero volviendo al tema del
centro penitenciario que se tiene un
hombre que se llama centro de
confinamiento del terrorismo es decir es
una cárcel de máxima seguridad dotada de
todas las condiciones y equipo
necesarios para que las personas que van
a estar internas por que son condenadas
por los jueces puedan cumplir sus
condenas en condiciones humanas también
y esto nunca se ha dicho que nadie
reivindica las condiciones de los
custodios o sea lo guardias que tienen
que cuidar a los reos en las condiciones
que recibimos nosotros el sistema
penitenciario ahora el tratamiento que
van a tener también ellos es un
tratamiento digno para su labor a efecto
de que puedan desarrollar el trabajo en
sin el estrés con el que viven ahora y
con una garantía fundamental y es que el
control de los centros penales lo va a
tener el estado Porque hasta la fecha lo
que habíamos visto era que el control de
los penales estaba en mano de los grupos
criminales de manera directa o de manera
indirecta por temor por corrupción con
las autoridades de los centros penales
anteriores ellos dirigían los crímenes
desde los centros penales Esta es otra
gran ventaja también con la que se ha
construido este centro de confinamiento
porque no está en ninguna zona urbana en
nuestro país los centros penitenciarios
están en las ciudades o alrededor de las
ciudades y eso ha dificultado tareas
como el cortarle las comunicaciones
porque desde los centros penales se
dirigían muchos de los delitos que se
cometían ahora este centro está
construido alejado de todas las ciudades
en una zona rural son
doscientos treinta hectáreas las que se
han utilizado ahora para construir el
primer módulo son solo treinta hectáreas
o sea quedan doscientas más para poder
construir otros módulos adicionales y
Tener suficiente espacio para que los
reos que los internos puedan trabajar
realizar labores productivas para su
autoconsumo y también para el
sostenimiento porque se está manejando
proyectos productivos que se van a
desarrollar y ellos podrán vender y
comercializar sus productos hablemos
ahora de otro tema Señor me refiero al
aborto y los derechos reproductivos en
El Salvador está prohibida la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo sin
excepciones no Incluso en Casos de
violaciones embarazos de menores de edad
hay casos que salieron a la luz no sobre
todo en 2022 Leslie Ramírez una joven
que sufrió una emergencia obstétrica y
dio a luz en una letrina fue condenada
50 años de prisión por homicidio
agravado otra mujer que también sufrió
un aborto espontáneo fue acusada de lo
mismo condenada a 30 años Cuál es su
postura al respecto de valor en algún
cambio en la legislación en esta materia
Pues mira en el caso personal mío esto
es un motivo de vergüenza personal de
tener una legislación penal de esa
naturaleza yo siempre he considerado que
hay estándares que los plantea
organismos internacionales como Naciones
Unidas y otras entidades que dan los
parámetros para que pueda haber este
tipo de interrupciones en lo personal
hemos presentado en una propuesta de
reforma constitucional un artículo en el
que nosotros sin referirnos al aborto
porque el aborto no es un tema de la
Constitución es un tema del derecho
penal decimos que el estado está
obligado a defender la vida la vida de
la madre y la vida del nacituros del no
nacido ambos tienen el mismo derecho a
vivir y cuando exista algún conflicto
entre ambas vidas será la ley la termine
con eso lo que estamos diciendo es que
debe de actualizarse la la normativa
penal para poder estar a la altura de
las circunstancias porque es cierto
causa vergüenza ver al Salvador en la
lista de países en los cuales mujeres
han sido condenadas como los casos que
tú mencionabas y por eso creo que es
tiempo de hacer una reflexión profunda
no en torno al aborto porque hablar del
aborto es hablar de la muerte y nosotros
hablamos de la vida del derecho a la
vida que tiene tanto la madre como no
nacido y el estado debe de regularlo de
manera en que se garanticen ambas vidas
y cuando hay un conflicto establecer
Cuáles son las causas mediante las
cuales se puede interrumpir en la vida
del nacituros hablemos ahora de economía
y un tema en el que El Salvador sin
lugar a dudas ha sido pionero Señor por
qué en septiembre de 2021 el bitcoin se
convertía en una moneda de curso legal
en El Salvador el gobierno no compró la
criptomoneda con fondos públicos en
medio de advertencias del riesgo no al
que quedan expuestos los recursos de la
nación por la inestabilidad del precio
de lo que es un activo digital que ha
perdido bastante valor no en el año 2022
algunos hablan alrededor del 60 por
ciento Cuáles son los objetivos de
apostarle al bitcoin evalúan quizás
riesgos a mediano largo plazo
No mira yo creo que la apuesta es a la
economía digital y el mundo avanza hacia
la digitalización de todos los procesos
y la economía no queda afuera en ese
sentido las criptomonedas que son
monedas de esta naturaleza fueron
reguladas en el caso del bitcoin como
moneda de curso legal en El Salvador en
el mes de septiembre del año 2021 la
recientemente hace menos de un mes
acabamos de aprobar la ley para los
activos digitales esto incluye además de
las criptomonedas otro tipo de activos
como los toquen o los nft los tokens que
son otro tipo de activos que El Salvador
va a reconocer como parte de esta nueva
economía hacia la que el mundo se dirige
el hecho de que el bitcoin como tal haya
descendido en su valor en los mercados
internacionales no ha implicado que El
Salvador haya tenido ninguna una pérdida
porque no
hemos vendido un solo bitcoin para decir
que compramos carros vendimos barato
simplemente se tienen ahí están como una
reserva de más el presidente lo dijo con
toda autoridad ahora que el bitcoin está
bajando vamos a comprar más bitcoin
porque es el momento de comprar vamos a
ver cuándo
esta criptomoneda sube su valor en el
mercado internacional y en ese momento
El Salvador va a poder tener otra visión
y otro valor a sus a sus a sus
criptomonedas en este caso a los bitcoin
Félix vicepresidente del Salvador
Muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
France 24 se pasó volando esta
entrevista
Bueno hasta la próxima hasta la próxima
Muchísimas gracias una vez más a nuestra
audiencia como siempre la invitamos a
que sigan informándose en el resto de
nuestra programación y también por
supuesto en France 24 punto com
[Música]